[Music]
his prose is so refined
it's bound to melt your mind my next
guest is the author of six best
best sellers which is more than i have
so i hate him for it
and his new book has marxist dopes on
the ropes it's called american marxism
joining
us now author and host of life liberty
and levine mark levy mark how are you
i am lovely how are you greg excellent
well by the way it's levin but that's
okay you know what i've been practicing
your last we're already off to a bad
start a
because i mispronounced your name and b
the audience applauded for you louder
than they applauded for me
plus you sold 400 000 books
in your first week which is like
insane should i take that as like a good
sign that america is not going to hell
i think you really should i i love the
left they say
what do you mean i'm a marxist well
let's see redistribution of wealth class
warfare you hate capitalism
uh you talk about overthrowing our
society you
oppose free speech and academic liberty
i don't know that kind of defines it
yes but i'm not really calling them
marxists i'm calling american marxists a
different kind of marxist you know
they're not
soviet-style marxists or mild types of
marxists they're homegrown marxists
and we grew them i mean we really did
our the our academic culture
they're now in human resources they're
all over my problem is though
mark when you talk to people about
socialism
communism marxism you actually have to
work backwards and define those terms
for them now
because no one's like they've forgotten
it
people say to me are you calling these
corporations marxists and joe biden
marxist
it's american marxism what exactly do i
mean by that and you are quite right
what i mean by that is
if you go back and you look where
climate change comes from
it comes from the d growth movement the
1970s in europe these were marxist when
you look at critical race theory which
comes at a critical theory
that was invented by a marxist from the
franklin school of marxism
and when you go back and look at the
root causes of these things that's what
it is so i am sick and tired of calling
people
progressives that's what they want to be
called or i'm a social
activist you know what a social activist
is it's a girl scout trying to sell girl
scout
cookies these are these are people who
are trying to overthrow our country
yep you know uh you brought up crt and i
think part of the reason why things like
that
have some uh success is they have their
own
secret incoherent language that's meant
to confuse people they have their jargon
and so when people fight it they go no
this is this is uh
they have their it's a destructive
ideology
and and then you have to explain it and
i find that the best way to fight this
stuff
is to is to create a simple definition
of what it is
which is like you know crt is
essentially a racist ideology wouldn't
you agree
i've got one for you i caught louis
farrakhan dressed up as scholarship
because that's basically what it is he's
a bigot he's a racist he hates white
people he's an anti-semite he hates
america
sounds like critical race theory to me
yeah no that's true
i have to tell you a story i back in the
days of red eye
uh my booker got an email from mark
levin
did i do it i got it she was so no no no
let me help you yeah it's like
loving levin levin god that should be
your nickname that should have been the
title of the show on sunday night love
and living how do you know it's not uh
good points so i was so excited
that you were coming on the show and
then of course it's not you it's a
different one it's some like lawyer from
new jersey
or d a um yes
but you know what my booker wouldn't
tell me until the day of so i'm so
excited that you're going to be on the
panel this has to be i don't know like
2008 2009.
and this guy's sitting there going that
is not him that is not him
i had all these questions by the way
jesse waters very lucky
yes very lucky that his book came out a
week before yours did
because you know what
very lucky that's all i gotta say this
if
let me just say this who knows but uh
this this book really has taken off
we're in our
we're going into the fourth week we're
at over seven hundred thousand copies
right now
uh there is a movement afoot i don't
think the media
understand it there is a movement afoot
it is a big movement it's going to be
effectuated in 2022 but even more than
that
you're going to start seeing a rise like
you did with the tea party and the
reagan revolution these are all things i
was involved in
earlier in my life i see it i smell it i
taste it it's here
i hope you're right congrats mark
thank you so much for coming on see you
soon god bless
god bless up hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else